quite a director James Gunn's upcoming
soft reboot the Suicide Squad will
likely be missing the originals most
divisive element in a recent Q&A
conducted on Instagram gun appear to
shoot down the idea of Jared Leto's
Joker appearing in his film in response
to a question from a fan gun was asked
how can you justify a Suicide Squad
movie that does not have Joker in it
Gunn's response was simple no one but me
and a few others know all the characters
in the movie but if the Joker isn't in
the film I don't think it would be
strange as he isn't part of the Suicide
Squad in the comics guns absolutely
correct that Joker isn't a part of the
Suicide Squad in the comics which is one
reason why some funds were puzzled at
the characters inclusion in the original
2016 film in the first place the version
of the Clown Prince of Crime presented
in director David Ayer Suicide Squad was
just a bit different from the cinematic
depictions of the past and most DC
diehards agreed that it was not in a
good way
letters Joker's pasty Whiteface and
slicked back a bright green hair were
about the only facets of the character's
physical appearance that the flick got
rights
but platinum grill and tattoos looked
absurd to many fans and letõs
hyper-stylized weirdly off-putting
performance did little to quell their
anger when it hit theaters I am NOT
someone who is loved
I'm an idea State of Mind Gunz principal
cast for the Suicide Squad could already
fill a good-sized bus the cast was
revealed last month with the release of
a one-sheet that included a whopping 24
names featuring both new and returning
cast members at this late juncture it
seems pretty unlikely that gum will
sneak their toe into the film and this
latest comments over confirms the fact
that the Suicide Squad will leave the
actors version of the Joker out in the
cold despite the extremely mixed
reception to Leto's Joker Suicide Squad
been enough bank that a solo vehicle for
the character and a team-up with Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn but briefly put
into production
both of those projects however were
unceremoniously axed earlier this year
and that's not even the strongest
indication that Warner Brothers was
completely soured on letters version of
the Joker let's not forget that the
trailer for the upcoming birds-of-prey
film makes it clear that especially as
far as Harley Quinn is concerned mr. J
is out of the picture there's also the
fact that a standalone Joaquin Phoenix
starring Joker movie made absurd amounts
of money and seems to have practically
guaranteed its star of Best Actor Oscar
nomination while it's pretty safe to say
that Phoenix's Joker is going to remain
strictly its own thing that doesn't mean
that letter was thrilled about the new
film recent reports have indicated that
the actor felt both alienated and upset
by the fact that the movie was even put
into development Joker's ridiculous
success and domination of the
pop-culture conversation this fall
probably haven't made Leto feel any
better about the whole thing at this
point it's not clear that letter would
return to the role even if he were asked
in the meantime he'll appear as a
titular living vampire in next year's
Morbius from Sony and Marvel if that
film even approaches the box-office
heights of venom then the möbius giga
could become a recurring one for Leto if
Sony and Marvel Studios continue to play
it as nice as they have been in the last
month or so he could even find himself
are facing off with some Holland's
wildly popular spider-man in any event
it's beginning to look more and more
like letters Joker will end up as a
one-and-done which will suit most fans
just fine
The Suicide Squad hits the big screen in
August 2021 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more loop of
but your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]